[Musik]
jetzt ist es soweit das buch ist da
sarah und baby bringt es mir jetzt mit
und ich habe es noch nicht gesehen ich
hab's mir aufgehoben für euch
kommt sie sagen
habt ihr so angeguckt seid ehrlich
ihr glück doch
dies prüfen muss
da ist
das baby auf der welt ja das so
anstrengend geburt als wenn man zwei
kindern
lengerich hohne lengerich
druckfrisch ach gott das war ganz
durchgekommen
der war
dies war freundlich die seite ist bei
jedem ja ja die startseite die muss die
musste ich bin geht dem buch hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute ist es endlich soweit ich zeige
euch in diesem video mein neues kochbuch
kochen für jeden anlass ich habe ja vor
zwei jahren es ist leider schon her mein
letztes buch herausgebracht das war ein
backbuch backen für jeden anlass und
darin findet ihr ganz viele kuchen und
torten viel gepäck und der titel kam
damals zustande weil ich mir eben
überlegt habe waren backt man denn
überhaupt kuchen und ich hab dann in der
community nachgefragt waren paktiert und
so eure kuchen zu welchen anlässen und
hat wirklich ganz viele verschiedene
anlässe gesammelt wird zum beispiel
geburtstag hochzeitstag taufe
schwiegermutter kommt oder einfach so um
jemanden zu überraschen und dann wollte
ich eigentlich einfach nur zum jahr zum
vervollständigen ein kochbuch machen was
daneben auch kochen für jeden anlass
bedeutet das heißt in diesem buch findet
ihr rezepte für fast jeden anlass und es
gibt einen ganz bedeutenden unterschied
zwischen kochen und backen beim kochen
ist nämlich so kochen das macht auch
noch für sich selber einfach um satt zu
werden abends mal kurz nach der arbeit
es ist schon immer was emotionales auch
aber kochen tut mir auch einfach mal so
um satt zu werden beim backen ist das
ganze noch ein bisschen emotionaler und
backen zumeist auch für andere das heißt
man möchte jemand anderem eine freude
machen und im seltensten fall stellt man
sich hin und sagt sich heute backen
schock kuchen nur für mich das kommt
vielleicht wenn man so einen heißhunger
hat und dann sagt okay ich habe es echt
schoko gelüste aber normalerweise ist es
so dass es packen immer so für andere
ist und das kochen ist oftmals auch mal
für sich selber oder eben auch von der
gesellschaft genau kochen für jeden
anlass soll im prinzip eine inspiration
sein für das tägliche kochen und backen
für das zubereiten verschiedener
gerichte von wird nicht ganz einfach und
ganz schnell bis zu aufwändigeren
gerichten und ich habe in diesem buch
einfach mal so die lieblingsrezepte
zusammengefasst die wir so in letzter
zeit hatten und ich habe in diesem buch
jetzt einfach verschiedene kapitel die
ich auch immer wieder umgeschmissen habt
wisst ihr dann letztendlich perfekt habe
okay das heißt ich mache einfach nur die
kategorie vorbereiten weg
finde ich auch gut weil man kann ja so
tipps immer nur so hin schreibt so tippt
lässt sich super abend vorbereiten und
am montag aufhören damit ich weiß
welches dieser basics ich benutzt haben
machen was am ende und das die gleiche
gleich genau ich würde solche
fragen die wir zum spiel zu stellen so
dass das alles gleich aussieht ist die
leute
und es ist ja nicht jeder im kochen und
backen beheimatet das heißt wenn manche
ist es so ein bisschen neuland und es
muss einfach noch ein bisschen mehr
erklärt werden andere die machen das
schon öfter aber ich denke dieses buch
ist einfach was für jeden und was jetzt
hier gemacht habe also wenn man das buch
mal aufschlägt dann habe ich vorne drin
einfach eine übersicht und ihr seht
einfach wie in einer zeitschrift
verschiedene gerichte und könnt euch
hier wirklich schön inspirieren lassen
euch die bilder anschauen und eben nicht
nur anhand des titels sondern auch
anhand der fotos einfach inspirieren
lassen und sagen okay heute habe ich
lust auf herz auf den schnecken oder
heute lacht die focaccia an und könnte
dann von bild zu bild springen und was
ich dann im anschluss gemacht habe nach
dem vorwort ich hab da einfach eine
kleine oder eine kleine große waren
konnte mit dabei und darin geht es
einfach um lebensmittel
grundnahrungsmittel es geht aber auch um
werkzeuge und dieses kapitel die wir
hier das wir hier gemacht haben da habe
ich einfach die ganzen lebensmittel
erklärt und vieles aus dem garten mit
verwendet ein bisschen was vom feld hier
nebenan und einfach noch ein bisschen in
der natur geschaut was hier vorne
antritt ist im buch habe ich dann noch
einfach verschiedene grundrezepte mit
dabei vorne drin zum beispiel
verschiedene saucen und dips die man
einfach immer zubereiten kann so dass
man einfach jedes mal was zu hause hat
vor allem auch wenn man mal schnell
hunger hat oder sich jemand spontan
ankündigt so dass man einfach immer was
zu bereiten kann und ich hab dann ganz
viele verschiedene rezepte wirklich auch
für jeden typ mit dabei das heißt jemand
der zum beispiel gerne fleisch ist da
ist was mit dabei jemand der sich gerne
lange in der küche auffällt da ist auch
was dabei aber es ist auch was für den
schnellen hunger dabei so dass man
einfach schnell mal was auftischen kann
oder auch was für spontane gäste und im
buch ist es auch so dass sich viele
rezepte die es schon gibt wie zum
beispiel in lasagne einfach neu
interpretiert habe und das heißt
klassische dinge die wir sowieso alle
leben entweder neu anrichten neue
zutaten mit rein oder komplett abwandeln
so dass immer wieder neue rezept ideen
entstanden sind wenn man die offene form
zur hälfte mit bolognese füllen dann die
nudel platten
mit
dünnen ungehobelten zucchini scheibe
belegen
mit einem dünnen gehobelten zucchini
scheibe belegen weil die spenden
feuchtigkeit an die nudel platte die
muss
die teil des geht die fähigkeit eine
nudelparty steht gar und dann tue ich da
gerade und cleggs von der soße rhein
rollers auf
eine rolle des next auf
so habe er dann die polonaise in der
auflockerung und stellt dann die rollen
so rein
so richtig so
naja
und dann kratzt schieße wie sie
ja ich weiß es sieht so schön aus
relativ gar kein ski sie hier das video
rolling sieht
aber wir waren sie in die rolle rein
[Musik]
ja
die zucchini spendet die feuchtigkeit an
die nudel platte
die sie spendet cremigkeit und aroma und
polonaise
bringt die farbe ins spiel
und kommt es ja
okay dann hamas dann machen wir jetzt
langsam als
wenn die reform hätte
was ich an der buchproduktion immer so
toll finde das für mich immer so ein
bisschen experimentieren küche also wenn
ich ein videodreh dann mache ich das
schon immer so dass ich fürs video das
rezept so gut wie möglich
perfektionieren und dann praktisch für
euch ab filme bzw ich weiß dann einfach
schon wie es schmecken soll und ich weiß
wie es aussehen soll und beim buch da
begleitet mich ja dann keine kamera das
heißt da experimentiere ich immer so ein
bisschen nach gucke ich dafür dass ein
bisschen kokosmilch da ein bisschen
sahne und da bin ich einfach total frei
im kochen und backen weil ich jetzt dann
erst das rezept sozusagen entwickle und
eben im gleichen moment mit schreibe und
ich habe jetzt über die jahre hinweg
also das jetzt mein sechstes buch und so
beim ersten buch habe ich noch ein
bisschen anders gearbeitet aber über die
jahre hinweg habe ich das schon für mich
so ein bisschen vom prozess herr
perfektioniert weil ich natürlich wusste
also anfangsphase immer so ich hab das
rezept gemacht dann mehr kurz bis sind
die zutaten mit aufgeschrieben und
irgendwann am ende buchproduktion die
ganzen texte verfasst und das war für
mich dann extrem schwierig da selber
noch mitzukommen was habe ich jetzt wo
verwendet und dieses mal habe ich jetzt
wirklich so gemacht dass ich am tag so
zwei drei vier gerichte gekocht habt mal
ein bisschen mehr mal ein bisschen
weniger je nach aufwand und dann immer
am gleichen tag sofort alles
mitgeschrieben und fertig geschrieben
damit hat auch keine fehler im buch
passieren dass ich nichts vergesse dass
die zubereitung schritte stimmt und ich
habe mir auch direkt immer im vorfeld
überlegt welchen step möchte ich dann
zeigen also ist es jetzt gerade wichtig
wie man es dass man sieht wie man das
gemüse schneidet oder ist es vielleicht
wichtiger dass man sieht wie man jetzt
einen aufwändigen prozess macht oder
einer aufwändigeren schritt und das muss
ich sagen war diesmal echt optimal und
dann konnte ich einfach hier werke utah
war mit dabei und hat mir immer so war
so meine rechte hand und hat mir immer
alles weggeräumt und zutaten schon
gerichtet wir waren da echt super
eingespielt und sarah und dann die
bilder machen und der benni hat dann
sozusagen denn ich es unser grafiker er
hat dann sozusagen von mir die texte
bekommen die ganzen infos wie ich etwas
aufgebaut haben möchte von sarah die
fotos und dann kommt er sozusagen alles
einfach schön gestanden
[Musik]
und was ich immer ganz schön fand also
die koch produktion ging er wirklich
über einen längeren zeitraum und ich
habe halt immer wieder zwischen den
drehs immer mal wieder am kopftuch
gearbeitet
auch so wird das ganze jahr hinweg damit
ich auch wirklich alle
regionalen und saisonalen zutaten
irgendwo auf verwenden konnte und ich
hatte auch immer zwei fleißige helfer
samira und die machen ja da auch ganz
gerne mit und mit denen wir dann immer
ganz schön raus im garten oder auch mal
in den wald um einfach zutaten zu
sammeln
[Musik]
zum kochbuch gehört natürlich auch dass
wir nicht nur in der küche kochen und
backen sondern dass ich euch natürlich
auch mitnehmen nach draußen in die natur
zum beispiel zu uns in den garten ich
zeige wo das gemüse wächst wie man
kräuter angepflanzt oder wir gehen jetzt
zum beispiel in den wald und sammeln
bärlauch und da beschreibe ich natürlich
auch in meinem buch wo es eben oder
worauf es eben ankommt deswegen habe
jetzt hier heute einen familienausflug
gestartet wollen beloch sammeln und dann
was leckeres zubereiten
was los
[Musik]
ich habe gewackelt sagt
geht man bei bild
stellt den behörden hin und geht bei von
rechts und links zu was rein ja also ok
gehen ein bisschen
hast du denn bier neben wald gefunden
was wäre
hast mir mitgebracht
nach einfach
wie
ist einfach ein apfel sowie ella
[Musik]
im grunde sind alle rezepte im buch
wirklich sehr alltagstauglich und für
jeden geeignet und vor allem habe ich
immer nur zutaten verwendet die man
überall bekommt die auch weitestgehend
sehr gesund sind aber trotzdem
abwechslungsreich und wirklich sehr
lecker
keine sorge es geht immer noch extrem
viel salz aus aber es ist nicht fair und
damit bei euch die salz zucker menge und
die salz pfeffer und gewiss menge stimmt
habe ich in meinem rezept immer alles
ganz genau angegeben in mess löffeln und
teelöffeln und allem weil nicht jeder so
geübte sind kochen und viele brauchen da
einfach das perfekte verhältnis zwischen
zutaten und gewürzen und je öfter man
kocht und je länger man kocht umso
besser wird man da noch im abschmecken
also probiert euch da auch ruhig ran
aber wie gesagt für kochanfänger ist
auch alles ganz genau angegeben und alle
die schon ein bisschen geübt sind im
kochen die können die rezepte einfach
als inspiration nehmen und auch selber
immer wieder abwandeln und die rezepte
sind auch so gemacht dass ihr wirklich
immer mal wieder zutaten austauschen
könnt ganz wie es euch gerade gepasst
[Musik]
hallo das ist jutta handy er
wahrscheinlich schon und jeder hat bei
uns eben märz angefangen gern im februar
im februar in zip und du warst da hat
sich also drei probetag ja bei uns und
da war ich ja mitten in der ortenau ich
habe im november bei dir drei tage zur
probe gearbeitet und da habe die
buchproduktion ich weiß nicht für
begonnen hat und das also relativ am
anfang ja sogar mitten drin und da war
ich dann ja erste mal dabei und das war
so richtig spannend weil ich habe mir
vorgestellt hab' ich wusste mir machen
was für das buch und habe mir dann
verfolgt nur hatten produktion da bin
ich mal gespannt weil du alles dabei
was weiß ich koche und
fotografiert und wie das so abläuft dann
kommt da macht ist dieser
tag ein student gleich hier fällt machen
dann kann ich ihnen zweiter schreiben
und dann kann man die nächste sache
richten
ich bin ich schon mal gedanken über das
nicht
wenn euch auch schon was rausgesucht und
da steht noch das dritte rezept für
sache bereits fotografieren und da denke
ich schaffe heute hier
den vorderrädern über wir sind dennoch
sehr wurde löffel gerade jungen ja
nur einmal
mein auge
sehr schön aus
mit fans gut
ja wir hatten immer so 234 gericht
lernen tag
da ging's zur sache und wenn man dann so
neue ist und so probearbeiten sind wir
sicher von seiner besten seite
also
hinter niemals und krampfhaft versucht
wo liegt was wo ich was drin so das ist
sicher ob in warschau
ich hab gesagt also das war nun wirklich
wer computer machen wir drei probetag
dass man auch gucken ob es zwischen uns
passt und ob die sympathie da ist ok in
einer harmonisch funktioniert und das
den drei tage auszeit murat ich glaub
ich glaube ich habe wahrscheinlich
wieder verschreckt wie kann man nur als
probetag ist das buch bei so einer
videoproduktion läuft schon auch mal
unter zeitdruck aber sondern
videoproduktion da ist ja alles schön
vorbereitet ich riecht dann immer
überlegt mir das vorher und buch wollte
war halt schon
zeitintensiv und stressig dann habe ich
dachte ich komme nie wieder ja ich denke
ich nicht dass
sie allein oder waschen
aber es war richtig gut und es gab immer
was leckeres zu essen
gekocht aber macht habe ich kann mir
noch daran erinnere als ich dann hier
angefangen hat und mir dann weiter im
buch macht hin wo man mal alle fotos
hier im studio und bürger verteilt hin
zum zuge wie der sommer kommt und so
bisserl eingeteilten ihn süß ist in
hauptgerichte und so
und dann weil wir ja so richtig gespürt
wie so richtig stolz war dass ich in
denen er ganze dingert dabei war ja ja
ja so richtig nach dem ersten drei tage
mit der utah als jetzt obama bewusst
wenn die frau bleibt dann ist was fürs
leben die kuh wurde würde über
stillleben und
hier seht ihr jetzt mal sondern
typischen alltag bei mir in der
buchproduktion also ich überlege mir
natürlich im vorfeld schon welche
rezepte ich zubereiten möchte dann wird
einfach drauflos gestartet und ich
überlege immer welchen schritt ich
zuerst zeige und man sieht auch schon
ganz deutlich dass die buchproduktion
bei uns einfach immer sehr aufwendig ist
weil sarah dann zwischendurch die step
by step fotos macht ich überlegt dann
immer welches foto oder welchen schritt
möchte ich jetzt zeigen dafür muss
natürlich auch der hintergrund immer
sauber sein die küche sauber seien die
zutaten gerichtet werden und deswegen
ist bei uns schon immer so ein kleines
küchen chaos während der buchproduktion
mutter hilft mir jetzt sarah hilf
schmiert wir machen die step by step
bilder und dann kommt immer das fertige
gericht direkt nach draußen zum foto set
und wird dort fotografiert und so läuft
es dann praktisch dass ich am tag drei
bis vier manchmal auch fünf manchmal
aber auch nur zwei rezepte schaffe je
nachdem wie viel auch von dem dahinter
steckt
sehr interessant und ich muss jetzt
immer noch seine buchproduktion zu mache
ich für mich oftmals
einfacher
wir entschieden
für welches wie entdeckt wirklich ganz
oft nicht wenn ich einschlafe zu
erhalten makler und plappert und jan
schmidt gemacht und ich denke wir
machen den kühlschrank auf und
untersucht was drehen wirst dann der
diesel rumpelt und gewalt wird wir
drehen
da habe ich nochmal schwierigkeit aber
disney blick waren das macht der unseren
kanal aus und machten sympathisch mal
steht der fonds wurde damals irgendwie
der murat mit irgendwie 100 millionen
menschen mal kommt eine studentengruppe
durch aber es ist schon immer sehr
aufregend der aber die auswahl der fotos
das fand ich auch ganz gut weil es
wirklich so war das mitten in der
buchproduktion ich hatte zwar schon mein
konzept erstellt aber wie gesagt immer
wieder umgeschmissen und dann habe ich
fragt sich anhand der bilder immer
gesehen da habe ich etwas mit charakter
ich habe mich schon was mit kokos macht
hier schon was mit fleisch und dann
konnte ich so immer wieder mich selbst
inspirieren lassen und gucken was ich
eben noch als nächstes machen möchte
unter dem motto war ich noch wieder ist
so gut wie
diesmal
tipps auf ein foto ein player soll ich
dann alle werbung solche um ein foto und
hier sind erklärt
kommt darauf an wenn der inhalt auf
einer seite passt ja wenn könig partners
aufsplitten das ist schon schön aus mit
dem roten bereich ja ich liebe wildreis
dabei bin ich ganz brav
so jetzt wieder vorbei
schoss mit fleisch immer weh heute aber
ich weiß das letzte mal rasche da hat
auch kurz rein guckt und dann hatte ich
auch gerade nur weh getan ist eine kunst
ist bei unserer geschichte aber sind
auch richtig tolle gerichte mit fleisch
geworden ja es ist halt ein buch für
jeden also sind viele vegetarische
rezepte finden aber auch mal was mit
gleich auch mal was mit film und ich
denke da kann sich jeder doch militär
aus und muss sagen ich bin wirklich wenn
du gesagt hast vom hoch zukunft
gesteigert alle disput zu übertreffen
wird sehr sehr schwer muss ich ganz
richtig stolz auf dich ohne witz und
jochen einst selber gemerkt was habt ihr
vielleicht gar nicht mitgekriegt ich
habe auch ein eigenes kochbuch gemacht
aber ich hab's die fans gerade leute
sich tatsächlich mit mir betteln und hat
sagt irgendwann so ein kochbuch zu
machen das kann doch nicht so schwer
sein ja ich mache mein eigenes im
tristan und ich meine antwort priester
nicht gelegen die rezepte gemacht zum
einen ist er aus so gut kochen können
ist das eine ja kunden aber christa sehr
gut kochen beibringen können ist noch
mal das andere ich meine das kann dann
mit sicherheit auch ihr habt ihr auch
die rezepte aufgeschrieben aber es geht
ja dann auch drum und buch zu gestalten
gestalten es geht darum die rezepte so
zu schreiben dass sie jeder versteht es
geht darum dass man vielleicht mit
warenkunde mit reinbringen oder eben die
zutaten können
angelegen natürlich die papierpreise
etwas gestiegen
das ist wirklich unglaublich dass ich
momentan in medien überall mit und
deswegen war es einfach zu teuer um ein
buch herauszubringen also mein buch
etwas zu teuer
deswegen kommt mein buch er nächstes
jahr aber es gefällt ihr denn an unserem
buch ganz besonders cool das alles drin
ist wirklich also konnten
von halt diese rezepte mit gemüse aber
auch rezepte für ja auch cool ja und was
für den kleinen und den großen hunden
genau ansonsten finde ich halt typisch
seine videos erklärt klein das ist jeder
versteht das war kein fehler macht ist
cool erklärt ansonsten alles also die
bilder sind toll die rezepte ich liege
die rezepte das heißt ab sofort kocht
morath mit samira und ella für die ganze
familie dafür sei also ja natürlich cool
es aussieht und es ist so eine richtige
platte mit kräutern haben die comfort
beibringen was zu trinken mit und hat
eine coole grillplatte war auf
grillrezepte sind tolle grillrezepte
gebratenes wintergemüse aber war schon
fleisch mit drin richtig kreativ
innerhalb dass wir alle dabei dass nicht
nur nur vegan veganer immer nur fleisch
fleisch es ist für alles was dabei und
weiß ja nicht nur beim kochen bleiben
soll sondern ein ganzes gericht versteht
ja schon immer auch aus einer vorspeise
einem hauptgang zwischen gerichten und
dann noch in süßen abschluss genau das
ist auch aktivierende gerichte drin das
kann richtig knallen also hier rezepte
okay kann es abgehen
auch wer macht's gut oder muss ich
wasche ja also ich glaube dass ihr jetzt
so gut es geht viel über das buch
mitbekommen habt und ich werde am 13 11
übrigens hammer es ist einfach der
hammer ich kanns ja ich werde am 13
übrigens in mannheim eine signierstunde
haben ja ich habe im neuen buch das
heißt falls ihr aus dagegen kommt könnt
ihr gern vorbeikommen wird auch ein
schönes weihnachtsgeschenk und da kann
ich nur schöne widmung reinschreiben
ansonsten gibt es doch einfach ab dem
ersten elf online bei uns auch cds -
shop.de oder in mannheim in unseren
stores wir haben es auch schon die
letzten jahre erwähnt unsere bücher gibt
es exklusiv einfach nur bei uns wir
haben wir wollen da einfach vermeiden
dass ist jemand irgendwie auf andere
online plattformen stellt die wir halt
vielleicht netze unterstützen wollen wir
haben es schon mal versucht den kleinen
buchhandel zu unterstützen aber die
kleinen buben haben es dann auch die
großen online er getan und das wollten
wir nicht ohne sie einzige grund asien
haben wir irgendwie alles für uns haben
möchten wir möchten einfach das ist ein
wert meines buches erhalten
gerne unterstützt eine kleine bücherei
oder oder buchläden unterstützt übrigens
auch und ich nur immer die großen ja und
e-books gibt es bei uns auch nicht weil
wir einfach sagen wir wollen den
buchdruck unterstützen und den erhalten
und deswegen gibt es unter eben nur in
gedruckter form es gab ja so lang wie
mannheim eine signierstunde und
ansonsten ich hoffe ihr habt ein
bisschen kriegen können wie viel arbeit
in dem buch steckt es ist wirklich ein
kurz herkommen paar fotos schießen und
raus und was ich weiß deswegen ist
vielleicht das nächste woche erste schon
zwei jahre definitiv denn ich muss sagen
so ein buch ist ja auch eine kreative
arbeit an der ich sehr sehr lange sitze
und ich muss da mir einfach meine
gedanken machen können und das ganze
schön als konzept erstellen können und
es oder wissenschaftliche hausarbeit die
ich dann vom anfang bis zum ende
perfektionieren möchte und deswegen
werde ich mich das nächste buch ihr
könnt auch gerne einfach mal in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr euch als
nächstes wünschen würde ich denke ich
wird wieder zu einem watt buch tendieren
weil es aber kochen backen im wechsel
aber nun kommen nächstes jahr mein buch
aus dem tristan zusammen den jüngsten
sternekoch zweistellig hoch deutschlands
ja also ich bin auch selber sei stolz
drauf aber ich hole ich mir leid zu tun
ab schuldig koch das gericht fertig
heute etwas vegan beispiel okay was
heute gibt es was wir gar nichts 23 was
rechts lecker
[Musik]
halt stopp seite noch dran sehr gut denn
ich habe mir gedacht da er jetzt das
video bis zum schluss angeschaut hat
mache ich doch noch ein gewinnspiel und
zwar gibt es noch fünf mal mein kochbuch
zu gewinnen und alles was ihr dafür tun
müsst ist was ihr dafür tun müsst ist
einfach in die kommentare zu schreiben
was denn euer lieblingsrezept ist also
was esse gerne mittags oder abends am
liebsten meine leibspeise
ich glaube bei mir gibt es gar keine bei
mir ist aber so ein bisschen
saisonabhängig im sommer esse ich gerne
leichte salate oder kalte suppen im
winter schon eher zu eintöpfe weil max
eisenstein lieblingsrezept
chili con carne das ist auch sehr gut so
richtig scharf
diese darf schneider weil mitarbeiter
sind immer ausgeschlossen aber aber ich
sehe der so ein buch okay
ich habe sogar ein abgewandeltes chili
con carne rezept drin an swat also
schreibt einfach gerne in die kommentare
was ihr lieblingsrezept ist und dann
werde ich das buch für euch natürlich
auch signieren also ab jetzt läuft das
gewinnspiel viel spaß dabei und finden
dann fürs zuschauen und euch noch einen
wunderschönen abend
was gibt bei uns halt noch zu essen
chili con carne klingt gut danke für den
tipp
[Musik]